in one word and I'm going to hold you to
one word what is your professional style
my professional stuff or in one word
Minh optimistic i'm here with jeremy
johnson the founder of what used to be
called tutor but is now to you which is
a known for providing for credit
graduate degrees you talk a little bit
about that yeah of course so we started
five years ago with a partnership with
the University of Southern California
and what we did and really the premise
was could you create an online academic
experience that had the same level of
quality as the best schools in the world
on campus could you create the same
academic outcomes online that you would
expect from these great schools on
campus and so our first program was a
master's in teaching with University
University of Southern California we
then built a master's in social work
with the University of California as
well masters in nursing with Georgetown
the first top 20 MBA available online
with UNC Chapel Hill master of laws that
watching University in st. Louis so
we've really built out what is often
described as the first generation of
incredibly high quality online graduate
programs and unlike some of the other
online education startups in our but
there are a number of them that are
trying to beach massive numbers of
people around you know you'd a city with
these these courses of 130,000 people in
them or whatever you're not doing that
you're doing a more of a high-touch a
small class kind of experience even
though it's online that's exactly right
in fact I would argue that what we're
doing is really almost the polar
opposite of what those companies are
doing and it's not to say that what
they're doing isn't a fantastic thing
for the world they're just multiple
things one can try to do if your goal is
to leverage technology to improve
education and so whereas their goal is
to distribute content knowledge as
broadly as possible and try to solve
that problem our goal is to find a way
to create online experiences that have
the same student outcomes the same level
of quality as on campus at the best
schools in the world and to do that
requires actual interaction with
professors small group classes real
admissions the ability to raise your
and exactly while in a live class and to
be able to challenge your professor and
have them challenge you that's
incredible now let's talk about the
business a little bit you've grown
enormously fast you got a 500 employees
now after five years and some of them
are a year in New York City and some of
them are in Washington DC if he tells
why we're sitting in this sort of semi
prison-like conference room here in a
bit about Manhattan yeah sorry about
that i wanted it odd you know sandy took
its toll on New York and our officers
are in chelsea piers and for those of
you who don't know Manhattan chelsea
piers are on what they call the Hudson
River which left the hudson river banks
yes exactly so it was basically exactly
where Manhattan was first struck by
Sandy and so nearly a month later we
still can't get into our offices and so
here we are in midtown Manhattan in
temporary office space unfortunately a
lot of your employees are in DC and you
were told me earlier that a lot of them
are involved in the sort of customer
service because you know the obviously
the universities are offering the
courses they have the teaching
experience they handle the admissions
but if I am in France and it's the
middle of night and I can't access what
what my course or by physics professors
about forgets that is training
somebody's there to help them that's
exactly right so what we do is provide
the infrastructure technology support
that allows a great university to offer
a program that is equally good online
has their own campus programs and so we
by design don't teach any of our
programs we have no control over the
admission standards over them everything
is the same as it would be on campus
you're taught by the same professors and
if you can't get in on campus you can't
get in on line what we do is allow for
those schools to shines we provide
student and faculty support we provide
support for the platform itself an all
tech development we provide really the
infrastructure that allows them to
leverage what they're good at on campus
which is a lot of things and to bring
that online in a powerful way so you've
raised a lot of money nearly 100 million
in venture capital and you need your
revenues by sharing it
tuition share sort of thing right yeah
that's exactly right morality is we are
completely aligned with the long-term
goals or university partners that's
really important for a partnership like
this to make sense and so we do a red
share on tuition and we have very sort
of fixed sort of obligations and
responsibilities with regards to making
sure that these programs maintain the
highest levels of quality as to our
university counterparts and partners and
that's it's really important that you
have things like a complete divide where
we don't control admissions and a really
important where where we do have the
ability to provide extraordinary support
to students and faculty who from time to
time just need it well of course every
all I barely can use my computer half
the time no matter the something's very
exciting has happened you guys very
recently you're expanding now into
undergraduate courses which is of course
a much broader arena and it must be
really exciting for you yeah it's
actually one of the most exciting
announcements we've ever had as a
company was literally a week a half ago
when we announced semester online and
semester online is a consortium of
really many of the top schools in the
country schools like Duke Washington
versus in st. Louis Vanderbilt
northwestern Emory coming together to
offer for credit undergraduate courses
to their students and others around the
country and world who can apply to take
their individual courses for credit to
to their standards in sedessa liz has
something remarkable before he started
this interview that so if I wasn't doing
a semester abroad in Egypt and I was
doing some you know great social work
there but I was a Duke student I mean
now i can continue taking my Duke
classes online one there I mean that's
that's exciting and brave new world
opens up a huge number of opportunities
for students you can confuse taking or
do classes or let's say that you are
always interested in a certain course at
Emory or Vanderbilt or Notre Dame you
could actually take one of those courses
as well you could actually expand the
offerings of what is possible for your
course selection in ways that has never
happened before and we and the partner
schools believe is going to be one of
the most exciting developments
in higher education this decade